in the early days of the iPhone Apple
made it really clear there was its
mobile software and then the Mac and its
operating system they were so separate
it felt like they didn't even know or
like each other slowly they've started
to play better sharing apps and designs
but with today's release of Mac OS 10
Yosemite to to take a giant leap towards
each other
Apple's finally making it I pad iPhone
and Mac function like a real family a
family that looks like each other and
talks to each other the advantage is so
big that if you're an iPhone or iPad
owner and don't own a Mac Yosemite might
make you consider buying one it makes it
harder to resist living in Apple's world
though there are still plenty of reasons
to play with Google and Microsoft hey
I'm over here just trying to blend in
with all these translucent menus yep
this place has been given a fresh coat
of iOS paint every icons gotten a
facelift even this guy the window
positioning buttons are flatter and the
notification panel looks like iOS is
today's screen with customizable widgets
I like the look but I'm really happy
everything's still in the same place you
can still swipe up on your trackpad to
see all your open windows or come here
and launch a new app you'll find
spotlight in the same place but it looks
slightly different it still searches the
entire system but now it gives you a
deeper preview of files and even
searches some websites and maps but you
might also start using Apple's own apps
more now that they work better across
devices and mail you can send bigger
attachments and there's a new markup
feature that lets you sign documents or
put monocles on your colleagues face
safaris toolbars have shrunk to display
more of a website and the search bar now
shows results in line though Google's
Chrome which I still find to be faster
has remained my default browser Apple is
also catching up to Google and Microsoft
on cloud storage with its new iCloud
drive on the Mac you can drag any file
to your drive though on an iPhone or
iPad you can only access the drive
through apps that recognize it Google
and Microsoft make Drive apps to ones
that work across iOS and Mac
but the most improved app award goes to
messages which looks nicer but also
syncs better than ever and that's just
the start of how Yosemite brings the Mac
closer to the iPhone in the iPad if your
Mac and iPhone are on the same Wi-Fi
network you can now take phone calls on
your Mac and also if you start an email
on your iPhone's Mail app and walk over
to your Mac it will pop right up it's
works great at the office but it hasn't
liked my home network Yosemite feels
like a leap ahead not because this place
looks any different or because there are
more powerful apps but because this is
the start of a new digital order where
our devices play to their strengths but
also collaborate with each other to help
us more see you know some people say we
look like sisters I don't really see it